In Italy, navy and coast guard ships pick up about 1,500 migrants in 24 hours,...
...most fleeing war and poverty in African regions.
In Israel, Israeli prime minister Benjamin Netanyahu...
...voices his disapproval of the recent Iran Agreement.
In India, Prime Minister Narendra Modi announces a National Air Quality Index Monday...
...to keep track of pollution levels in ten of its cities.
In an unprecedented move, China says it helped ten countries...
...evacuate 225 of their citizens from Yemen.
And finally from Switzerland, after a two-year hiatus...
...scientists at the European Center for Nuclear Research...
...restart their "Big Bang" Large Hadron Collider.